if you didn't know this month is my  birthday  and i have wishlists for both amazon and  etsy both in descriptions of my videos  now under normal circumstances i would  have let  packages accumulate and i would do like  maybe a live stream of unboxing but  you know after what the last year has  been i'm impatient and i've started  opening stuff up early so  i'm just going to show it off in some  shorts first  this is something that i intend to add  to my standard renaissance fair outfit  once those are allowed to happen again  it's just cool it's just cool and i like  it i like that the uh  cork actually comes out and it's not  just a prop and i know this doesn't look  too exciting  but this black backdrop  is something i have wanted for the  purposes of tick tock videos because  i don't actually have like a properly  blank  wall in my house so  this will get some use i'll keep you  posted thanks everybody